speaking of brando you know you you
because you played carlo right now
apparently there was a allegedly a story
he didn't want you to play carlos
something happened on set when i spoke
with him what happened with that it was
not even a set
i went up the the first rehearsal oh
that's how crazy my life is another
thing
in all the places they could have the
rehearsal
for the godfather all the places
they have at 119th street in of harlem
patsy's i thought tony salerno's joined
i'm there all the time
that's where they found it they want to
have it in the back room
or all kinds italian food's going to be
served
so i went up early
i come in i'm all dressed in a briony
suit and i'm watching and who's at the
at the bar
angel cheesecake
i mean guys you can't believe real guys
tony parkside federici i mean
everybody's there they said what are you
doing here i sent them here because i'm
there normally at night when they're
zigging that games because i used to
bring midnight loans they needed ten
thousand eight five thousand go up and
bring it to them the games last till six
in the morning that's what i used to do
again jump in a cab take money and do it
that's what i i wasn't no mob guy i was
an errand boy
so they said what are you doing
i'm here for the movies
my movie i see the godfather says what
are you going to do is i'm playing carlo
get out of here you're not an actor i
said i'm playing and sure enough they
came out uh mr russo rehearsal is going
to start i said told you so i go in
there
brando
they had before he brought him into the
room they said no i contacted marlon
brando nobody approached him
and then they brought god in
i mean all these young thespians marlon
brando was like their guy
was he the biggest actor the in the
world at that point marlon he was
but he still recognized
for his skill i mean what he did
so he said this guy at that time who was
in the early 70s yeah who would be the
biggest can early 70s i don't even know
but he was declining i mean after the
waterfront well i mean he anyway
long story short he comes over to me
so i'm saying everybody came over to me
he says and i'm dressed i mean still
only hating it
combat boots diane keaton my gardener
dress better than her i mean this is
movie star i mean today you see these
movie stars they they i like the old
guys
where they dress every day
people see me like in beverly hills they
said where you going so what do you mean
why are you all dressed i said i'm out
there for lunch
they're in sweats they look like bums
anyway
brando says to me
you're a big tv actor no you got a big
movie coming out i said no
he's well you're not on broadway i know
everybody on broadway i said you're
right again i switched as a quiz show
so he says who'd you study with i said
what are you talking about study what
so he calls cobra over he says francis
and i never broke down the script i got
the script i wanted to be in the movie i
think look at him be a movie star he's
questioning who you are what's your
resume why are you in this movie why am
i in this movie you knew everybody else
why they were there yeah you know
everybody's saying richard conte john
morley these people
yeah james conn dave scott robert duvall
jane cotton just had brian piccolo
slowly on tulla was the biggest stevie
yet
so there's johnny russo no resume no
nothing marlo marlon brando's
questioning why you're even there right
so now i don't know protocols the first
time i'm on even a rehearsal
so i knew this guy's going to try to get
me fired
i couldn't
go to the neighborhood
everybody in the neighborhood i told
them in the movie already
so i said to coppola i said go over
there a minute you can't dismiss the
director not even in a rehearsal and he
left
so the whole room went dead silence they
were like you know outside the door
i said come over here a minute i put my
arm on they told me not to look at him
now i got my arm on him around brando
brandon's and i walked him in the back
because i don't want to embarrass him i
walk him in the back where the games
were because they knew there was no game
i'm nose to nose like this microphone
let me just tell you something mr brendo
you screwed us up for me you hear what
i'm telling you look at me
you screw this up for me i will suck on
your heart you will bleed out right here
don't do this
he stepped back and he said
that was brilliant you could really act
i was ready to whack the guy are you
crazy
he was going to change to ruin your life
and you were actually i was legitimate i
was out what would i wouldn't be sitting
here right now think about it i wouldn't
be having this company i don't want to
have nothing i mean i mean you probably
say made the money but you got to
realize think about it from this
standpoint
uh
what is the main scene you remember from
american history x
what's the main scene from american
history x there's two scenes when he
shoves his face into the concrete
concrete is one of them okay what's the
other one the monologue at the table
with his family sitting there ten
minutes yeah where edward norton just
absolutely crushes it right
okay what is the main scene from
gladiator what's the main thing give me
the two main scenes from gladiator what
are the two scenes
it's gonna be most people are gonna give
the one scene from gladiator the
the scene where they're in the middle
and he fights joaquin phoenix that's the
revenge that's and then he grabs it here
and then the other scene is that you're
gonna like i've watched this scene a few
thousand times i can't get enough of it
is when he comes he turns his back he
gets on the ground and he says show your
face gladiator right he says he turns
his face he says show your face who are
you and he says i'm such and such right
you know father of a maximus um husband
of a murdered and i will get my
vengeance in this life come on
that's a scene right so you go to these
movies
there are scenes that are okay now go to
godfather go to godfather one what are
the main scenes that you remember
what are the main scenes that people
remember from
godfather this is one yeah the one the
one you did is one of them you know it's
not a uh so
so to be there and then uh uh act with
the lineup of people that were there
maybe marlon brando wasn't peaking at
the time but brando has been like but
you know there's a movie today's pacino
right but you talk about who was the
lineup who did you do who was who wasn't
in the lineup right uh
khan you got
a younger but even the older guys
richard conte sterling hayden
john molly
just a ridiculous lineup to be around it
what what was uh i've asked this before
but again
different audiences pewdiepie podcast
vitamin is
movie comes out
the day before the movie comes out
the world doesn't know who you are they
know you're from different places but
they don't know who you are well they
didn't really know me yeah well because
they knew me by the kid in fact most
people realized i'm johnny russo were
you 27 28 won the movie when you shot i
was i was uh yeah 27 27 okay 27 28 so
you haven't yet you've been in the
circles maybe you hung out with these
guys and you know the relationship you
wouldn't be doing the movie if you
didn't have those contacts there's no
way in the world right you're going to
be picked up for this guy's movie couple
of the book all this stuff
movie comes out
you're on the big screen you're sitting
there watching it
how did life change a week later a month
later a year later
that that day
that quickly because this is a time with
no social so there is no dm
instagram facebook everywhere
and see i had a different situation that
i talk about now i didn't then
because
on june 28 1971
that day
at nine o'clock in the morning i get a
phone call from a guy called tommy
belotti
who was shot down years later with paul
castellano by john gotti in front of
sparks he was the only boss of jenna
vase family by then but then he was just
an errand boy
and he said to me are you going to the
rally the big rally that they had for
the italian defamation league the year
before they had a hundred thousand
italian americans
now they had the rally going while we
were still shooting
june
pull that up june 28
1961
that rally you'll see you won't believe
so he says you're going to the rally i
said yeah you should know you're not
he's really talking about it i said i'm
on the dais he's i don't care if joe
columbo is sitting in your lap
you can't go
so i'm saying what i'm screwed
joe colombo got me the part
so i called barry slonic if i didn't
call barry slotnick
and say what i'm saying to you right now
i wouldn't be here look at that rally
[Music]
that's central park south that's
columbus circle of the end
so i i tell barry i was buried give my
apologies to joe i said i can't go i
have a stomach flu thank god i thought
fast enough i can't sit anywhere but
another toilet
and i was staying at the park lane hotel
because i wanted to stay because well
everybody's waiting outside the door
every day my apartment's two days two
doors over i was sleeping over there
i go out the back door on 58th street
take the subway downtown i'm not
downtown
a couple of minutes and they
shoot joe colombo wow
then they killed they shoot the kill
they killed 13 people that day
so now they're doing the investigation
of the deus you know all the shots that
they take there's one chair
that has johnny russo and it's empty
it's got my name on it instead of my ass
on it
so now
organized crime comes looking for me fbi
comes look at me and the colombo family
want to know why i wasn't there
and junior persico who just passed in
jail
one of the toughest guys in the world
i mean he took over that family while
joe stayed in a coma for five years
over that shooting then he died
but
i had to go to the world premiere under
all of that
i snuck in and snuck out i just wanted
to be there for the pictures i didn't
sleep because as soon as i sat down they
would come and got me because they
wanted to question me
and thank god barry schlatnik i made
that call because he strained out with
the columbus but not with organized
crime
he said he had nothing to do with that
what are you talking about because they
want to know you know he's called me
they had the stomach flu but if i didn't
call barry they would have whacked me
because they figured i knew
you know they killed everybody else
the last guy they killed was an
assassination they did
in uh umberto's clan house when they
shot joe gallo because joe gallo
arranged for the shootings to kill joe
colombo
i mean this thing was going on for a
while
how long did that whole thing last
during that time that time about 18
months man okay that's a long time for
that so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]